[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport le
magazine est consacrée comme vous le
savez à l'actualité sportive dans le
département a c'est parti pour le
sommaire golf l'open de france est
clôturé ce dimanche par la première
victoire d'un suédois sur les greens de
50 ans divine alexander noren a réussi à
arracher la 10e victoire de sa carrière
devant des cadors comme le numéro deux
mondiale justin thomass les détails dans
ce magazine golf toujours nous avons
rencontré pendant l'open de france
pascal grizot l'eau président du comité
ryder cup 2018
nous avons fait le point avec lui sur
l'organisation de la compétition trois
mois avant le début des hostilités
interview à suivre si glissement à julie
est à l'honneur la semaine dernière les
championnats de france sur route était
organisée dans la ville au rang des bois
réunis pendant les trois jours de
compétition plus de 600 coureurs à des
milliers de spectateurs coup de
projecteur dans ce magazine l'actualité
sportive de la semaine c'est maintenant
sur tv 78
[Musique]
je vous disais dans les titres la 102e
édition de l'open de france de golf
s'est clôturé ce dimanche 1er juillet
par une victoire sur le fil du suédois
alexander noren d'une première pour le
joueur
les tricolores n'ont eux a pas brillé le
premier français michael lorenzo vera
terminant 16e position des images de
nicolas landry un montage de eyes est
déjà là il est le premier suédois à
soulever le trophée sur l'open de france
alexander noren 35 ans a réussi à
dompter le parcours de l'albatros avec
un score de 67 finale alors qu'il était
parti avec un déficit de sept courts
début de journée sa dixième victoire
chez les professionnels
c'est génial
j'ai été proche de gagner cette année en
amérique et j'ai été ensuite à deux
coups de la victoire de française comme
molinari a white wolf
quand vous êtes si proche vous voulez
vraiment cette victoire
et c'est un sentiment incroyable de
l'avoir aujourd'hui et si alexander
noren l'a emporté c'est aussi parce que
les autres cadors présent qu'elle est
l'espagnol john rabe a dû se contenter
d'une cinquième place son compatriote
sergio garcia terminent le huitième à
égalité avec le numéro deux mondiale
justin thomas
l'américain était surtout venu pour
prendre ses repères sur l'albatros avant
la ryder cup en septembre prochain
c'est un bel endroit c'est un super
parcours une superbe ville et j'ai
vraiment aimé venir ici cette semaine du
côté des tricolores on l'attendait le
numéro un français alexander levy le
chouchou du public français
ce dernier terminera finalement une
décevante 65e place au classement
seul michael lorenzo-vera arrive à se
hisser dans le top 20 en terminant 16e
position avec une carte de 68 le
dimanche c'est toujours bon
très bon j'ai pas non plus fini très
très haut je pense que c'est pas une
un truc à retenir par rapport aux autres
français je pense que le monde c'est de
se battre pour faire mieux que le top 20
si les français n'ont pas su saisir leur
chance avec cette victoire sur le futur
parcours de la ryder cup le suédois
alexander noren pourrait définitivement
convaincre le staff de le prendre dans
l'équipe européenne
réponse au plus tard le 12 septembre on
continue à parler de cet open de france
où vous les avez sans doute aperçu sur
les images du reportage précédent les
spectateurs sont venus nombreux sur les
greens du golf national de saint quentin
en yvelines pour voir le numéro en
france alexander levy ou le numéro deux
au mondial justin thomass des images
d'eux patrick jacques de dixmude et de
nicolas landry l'open de france de golf
a fait recette cette année plus de
quarante huit mille spectateurs se sont
rendus au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pendant les
quatre jours de compétition
l'une des principales raisons le plateau
de joueurs qui réunissait cette année
des têtes d'affiché de la discipline au
niveau du du plateau on n'a jamais ou
jamais été aussi beau
justin thomas mery qu'un fort
sympathique qui nous fait l'honneur
d'être là sergio garcia qui n'est jamais
venu ici
ce qui est important parce que c'est un
joueur culte de l'équipe européenne
notamment le numéro deux mondiale justin
thomass a attiré toutes les attentions
conférence de presse sa salle était
pleine à craquer pour capturer les
premiers clichés de l'américain de 25
ans à saint quentin en yvelines sur les
greens et spectateurs ont suivi avec
attention c'est parti
c'est un homme de grands grands talents
qui ont une personnalité forte qu'à une
concentration exceptionnelle qui ne
s'énerve pas ou très peu qui qui est
perplexe c'est un monsieur c'est un
gentleman du golfe
je trouve que c'est bien parce que voilà
devant les grands joueurs c'est quand
même mieux quand il est vrai match de
foot si il ya bien eu contre dortmund
c'est d'aller voir et chantilly contre
contrat d'hyères c'est sûr non non je
pense que c'est bien d'avoir des grands
joueurs ça ça permute le mois de grandir
encore une fois le terrain de jeu était
l'autre attraction de ces quatre jours
de compétition le parcours refait à neuf
pendant près de dix mois pour la ryder
cup à torturer les joueurs et fasciné le
public c'est un golf extrêmement
complexe et qui a fait beaucoup beaucoup
de progrès au fil des années et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui enfin aujourd'hui et on
va avoir un spectacle et tony le rendez
vous est donc pris pour la ryder cup du
28 au 30 septembre prochain cette
fois-ci 60000 spectateurs quotidiens
sont attendus sur le site
on reste sur les greens de saint quentin
en yvelines vous le savez désormais tous
la ryder cup l'équivalent de la coupe du
monde du golf qui opposera l'europe aux
états unis sera organisée sur le même
parcours que l'open de france du 28 au
30 septembre prochain pour faire le
point sur l'organisation nous avons
rencontré sur le site pascal grizot le
président du comité ryder cup france
2018 exige alaa pour le montage
l'open de france se déroule actuellement
sur les greens de saint quentin en
yvelines à mes côtés pascal grizot
qu'est le mister ryder cup
pascal grizot est-ce que cet open de
france vous rassure encore plus dans
l'organisation de cette ryder cup 2018
c'est évident que si l'open se passe
bien c'est un bon tempo on est
maintenant
à trois mois de ce grand événement que
tout le monde attend avec impatience
donc dire que l'open de france et une
répétition pas tout à fait parce que on
peut pas comparer le volume par exemple
de spectateurs que l'on aura pour la
ryder cup par rapport à cet open de
france mais en tout cas si l'open de
france se passe bien ça nous permet de
tester quand même un certain nombre de
choses en étant pas tout à fait en
configuration de ryder cup sera
multiplié par combien le nombre de
spectateurs
aujourd'hui on doit avoir à peu près
5000 personnes et on aura soixante mille
donc c'est en tout cas par plus que 10
c'est certain est-ce que vous êtes prêts
c'est la question je pense que tout le
monde vous pose ici sur les greens de 51
divine à accueillir cette ryder cup
ça va être dans quelques quelques jours
quelques mois écoutez je veux pas
paraître prétentieux mais oui on est
prêt et la raison pour laquelle on est
prêt c'est qu'on y travaille depuis
maintenant plus de dix ans donc s'il ya
trois mois de l'événement n'était pas
prêt on aurait quelques questions à se
poser
maintenant il ya toujours des réglages
mais en tout cas il n'y a rien
aujourd'hui
qui nous dit que cette édition de la
ryder cup française ne sera pas une
belle édition
est ce qu'il ya des zones d'ombré encore
où tout a été planifié
revue non non non non enfin franchement
j'ai bien on a pas de zones d'ombré mais
comme je les dis on n'a pas de c'est
aussi un peu normal quand on travaille
et qu'on élabore un projet comme ça dix
ans en amont on a eu le temps d'y penser
pendant le dossier de candidature
ensuite depuis 2011 date à laquelle on
nous a donné cette chance de pouvoir
organiser la ryder cup qui est devenu
très rapidement aussi une grande
responsabilité
et bien voilà on délivre toutes les
promesses qui ont été faites et des
promesses qui avaient été bien pensés
pour pouvoir être tenus sur le plan
sportif on attend évidemment tous en
france la venue d'un joueur français ici
pour la ryder cup en septembre prochain
est ce que ça sera possible alexander
levy ne se donne avec à l'heure actuelle
aucune chance d'être dans l'équipe 0 %
de chance est ce que vous pensez comme
lui il aura aucune chance à votre avis
non je pense que
ce qu'a voulu dire alexander ces cas
aujourd'hui si on regarde le classement
et il a zéro chance puisque il n'est pas
dans les classements des 12 meilleurs
joueurs européens maintenant il n'est
pas si loin non plus donc je pense qu'il
s'est donné les moyens de pouvoir faire
partie de cette équipe maintenant dans
la carrière d'un golfeur c'est
évidemment très important de jouer la
ryder cup
j'ai envie de dire que ce serait très
bien qu'ils puissent jouer la ryder cup
en france maintenant s'il la joue pas là
moi je lui souhaite de jouer les
prochaines et de toute façon pour ce que
alexander levy apporte aux toiles
français je le remercie tous les jours
alexander levy qui ne viendrait pas ici
sur les greens de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ça serait une
déception vraiment à votre avis je pense
que ce serait avant tout une déception
pour lui pour nous le succès de la ryder
cup va pas se mesurer au fait qu'il
puisse y avoir ou pas un français c'est
sûr que y aurait une saveur spéciale si
on avait un français maintenant si on a
pas de français la ryder cup pour
mesurer son succès il ya un tas de
paramètres que le fait qu'il y ait un
joueur c'est un des paramètres mais il y
en a d'autres sur lesquelles on va se
baser pour que cette compétition qui est
un succès ça sert à communiquer quand
même un français a évidemment les
champions ont toujours c'est un levier
merveilleux pour la pratique du golf est
en tout cas pour intéresser les médias
c'est toujours mieux quand on a un
champion français
maintenant il faut pas oublier que des
français qui est jouer la ryder cup on
en a déjà eu
on a eu thomas levet on est jean van de
velde plus récemment on a eu victor
dubuisson et c'est vrai que très peu de
deux mois avant la ryder cup à
gleneagles
on pouvait ne pas être certain que
victor jousse est cette ryder cup et
pourtant il a joué donc attendons de
voir ce que vont donner les gros
tournois qui arrive maintenant il ya
quelques tournois des rolex et reese il
ya également des tournois majeurs cet
été auquel alexander levy est certain de
participer donc une bonne performance
dans ces tournois là peut lui donner des
chances de jouer la ryder cup
vous le disiez les français attire
forcément les médias comment faire pour
intéresser les médias qui ne suivent pas
forcément toujours le golf l'idée ce
serait vraiment de mettre en prime time
le golf à la télévision pendant la ryder
cup
ici en france écoutez d'abord ce qu'il
faut donner aux médias c'est des choses
qu'ils fassent ce qu'elles puissent s'y
intéresser au golf je pense que la
fédération en faisant en sorte de
d'accueillir la ryder cup vous donne les
moyens en tout cas de parler du gol
d'une façon positive en tout cas c'est
la raison pour laquelle vous
m'interviewer aujourd'hui et ça c'était
des choses qui n'existaient pas avant
cette candidature de ryder cup
donc oui la ryder cup et c'était la
raison pour laquelle la fédération avait
décidé de quand date est candidate et
doit être un levier pour nous permettre
de mieux développer la pratique de notre
jeu de golf en france et je pense que ça
va atteindre ses objectifs
on parle évidemment beaucoup plus de
golf et de façon beaucoup plus positive
qu avant et après la ryder cup l'image
du golfe aura définitivement changé en
france vous avez sentiment qu'on est
peut-être un tournant vraiment pour le
golf français en gros ça passe ou ça
casse
avec cette ryder cup non moi je suis pas
comme ça je veux dire il faut qu'on
mettre tous les moyens pour que ça passe
alors
évidemment il ya plusieurs paramètres le
fait d'avoir des champions on a des
champions de très bons joueurs mais
peut-être pas encore le champion
iconique mais remarquez ce qui s'est
passé en allemagne qui a eu des très
grands champions comme bernard longueur
ou comme martin kaymer ce n'est pas pour
ça que la fédération allemande s'est
développée plus que la fédération
française de golf donc un champion ça
suffit pas à la fédération a fait
quelque chose d'unique au monde c'est le
développement des pratiques des parcours
compact urbain sans parcours compact
urbain
il ya 98 qui ont déjà été construits par
rapport à notre objectif de 100 et puis
bien évidemment l'accueil de grands
événements et là je pense qu'on va être
servi on à la ryder cup en 2022 la
fédération vient de déposer ce matin son
dossier de candidature pour accueillir
les championnats du monde sur le même
parcours de saint quentin en yvelines et
ensuite en 2024 on aura les jeux
olympiques donc le soufflé ne va pas
descendre
après la ryder cup au contraire on va
faire en sorte qu'ils aient toujours des
événements qui puisse susciter l'intérêt
des médias
alors même s'il n'y a pas de français en
septembre prochain ici à saint quentin
en yvelines
il ya quand même un élément qui fait
beaucoup parler lui c'est le parcours
ici tout le monde est unanime le
parcours c'est peut-être l'un des plus
durs au monde
l'un des plus beaux vous allez sentiment
là aussi le bleu plus beau ça je me
permets pas je préfère que ce soit les
autres qui le disent maintenant
évidemment que quand c'est le parcours
qui appartient à la fédération française
de golf en tout cas grâce aux
collectivités grâce à l'état on a pu
continuer à investir de façon permanente
sur ce parcours pour qu'ils soient prêts
à à pouvoir accueillir les plus grandes
échéances que sont la ryder cup et les
jeux olympiques donc en termes de beauté
écoutez c'est certain les joueurs
l'apprécient beaucoup en terme de
qualité d'entretien les moyens qui ont
été mis par la fédération ces dernières
années permettent grâce à toutes les
équipes d'avoir effectivement un
parcours capable de répondre aux
échéances et autre challenge dunes ryder
cup
il est très compliqué c'est un parcours
qui est difficile
mais ce qui fait aussi que bien souvent
ce sont les meilleurs qui gagnent et
c'est un parcours très sélectif et qui a
un intérêt notamment en match play qui
sera la formule de la ryder cup je pense
qu'on va avoir un très très beau
spectacle dans la question qu'est ce
qu'on peut vous souhaiter pour ces
prochaines semaines avant l'organisation
de ce fameux événement aurait coûté que
tout se passe bien que sur tous les
spectateurs qui auront fait l'effort
d'acheter un billet soit récompensé voir
un spectacle d'exception qui n'est
jamais venue en france qui reviendra à
mon avis pas tout de suite que les
médias que les partenaires que tout le
monde soit très satisfait de ce
spectacle unique et puis que pour notre
pays
cette compétition laisse un héritage
positif de la création de richesse le
fait qu'on puisse avoir de beaucoup plus
de golfeurs dans notre pays que les
jeunes aient envie parce qu'ils auront
vu la ryder cup à la télé est identifié
à ces grands champions 1 voilà il ya un
tas de choses que cette ryder cup doit
pouvoir nous apporter
merci beaucoup pascal grizot la ryder
cup ce sera du 28 au 30 septembre sur
les golf le golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines pour pouvoir la
ryder cup sur le territoire français la
ministre des sports laura flessel et les
responsables du groupe la poste sont
venus vendredi dernier au golf national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines en plein
open de france pour présenter le futur
timbres à l'effigié du trophée de la
compétition
imaginé il ya deux ans est en vente
depuis aujourd'hui il est édité à 1
million 20000 exemplaires au prix d'un
euro 30 internet qui lui permettra
d'expédier des lettres dans le monde
entier on écoute les réactions
c'est la troisième fois qu'on sort un
timbre sur le golf la première c'était
en 1980 un timbre dont la thématique
était la ffg la fédération française de
golf
la deuxième c'était en 2006 sur l'open
de france
et là c'est la troisième pour fêter
évidemment un événement incroyable à
rider la ryder cup
il est très bon il représente tellement
l'engagement collectif de gérer de toute
une nation de tous les acteurs publics
privés du monde du mouvement sportif de
la poste pour trouver ce timbre il
faudra vous rendre dans certains bureaux
de poste ou directement au musée à de la
poste à paris
comme chaque lundi je vous propose
maintenant de vous immerger dès à
présent dans la ryder cup et de
découvrir chaque semaine des anecdotes
sportive sur le tournoi
aujourd'hui le directeur technique
national de la fédération française de
golf christophe muniesa se prêtent au
jeu au regard des
[Musique]
2004 c'est une ryder cup dont je me
souviens à plus d'un titre
raison particulière et personnelle la
première c'est que c'est la première
haider cup à laquelle j'ai assisté en
vrai c'était à dans la banlieue de
détroit oakland hills et la deuxième
c'est parce que cette édition de la
ryder cup également il y avait un
français le premier français à voir
jouer la ryder cup 199 jean van de velde
à brooklyn et là c'était thomas levet
qui s'était qualifié pour bien faire le
voyage au sein de l'équipe européenne
cette ryder cup quand on la voit en vrai
c'était déjà un formidable avant coût de
ce qu'on s'apprête à vivre dans quelques
mois au golf national en france
ce qui frappe c'est en le gigantisme de
l'événement encore plus quand on est sur
le sol américain tellement les femmes
américains sont déchaînés le public
les médias l'ambiance très particulière
d'une ryder cup avec ses matches en
opposition directe c'était aussi donc
une découverte pour thomas levet qui
pendant l'épreuve
lui-même se confiait en nous disant j'ai
joué des tonnes de championnat j'ai
remporté des épreuves sur le european
tour
et pourtant il n'ya pas un événement
comparable en termes de ferveur en
termes d'ambiance en terme d'intensité
et il nous disait lui-même que planter
sa balle sur le tee du 1 en ryder cup
qu'il n'y avait pas d' expérience
comparable dans toute sa carrière de
sportif professionnel donc une saveur
particulière à plus d'un titre
couronné aussi par une nouvelle victoire
de l'équipe européenne à l'issue des
trois jours de compétition
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après cette large page golfique un mot
de cyclisme quatre jours de compétition
pour connaître les champions nationaux
sur route les yvelines accueillait la
semaine dernière les championnats de
france un retour dans la région
vingt ans après linas montlhéry huit
titres décernés sur les routes de
mantes-la-jolie ce dimanche c'était
l'épreuve en ligne des professionnels
masculins un reportage de mélanie poquet
et 2 à nicolas landry un départ matinal
pour les 151 professionnelle mais leur
n'a pas refroidi les supporters et les
coureurs ce dimanche 1er juillet pour
l'équipe pas pour un personnellement
mais pour toute l'équipe fdj faut qu'on
garde le maillot ils sont cons si on s'y
prépare voilà allez dans la tête c'est
fait on le sait depuis quelques mois que
ça sera de bonheur donc voilà on s'y
habitue on en est on est on s'y préparer
en amont on a essayé de serrer un peu
plus tôt que d'habitude les jours
précédents le natif de versailles a
couru quasiment à domicile sur ses
routes d'entraînement dans le public du
soutien celui de ses proches
on les appelle à 25 km d'ici donc on est
devenu amis famille pour but premier
l'encourager au départ de 253 km
quelques uns des meilleurs du peloton
français allaient très bon d'informer et
bono signature de procès
évidemment en ligue 2
le champ pénal et dans la gestion la
route du tour et on espère garder
toujours motivé à quelques jours du
départ du tour de france voilà notre
départ du championnat de france est
toujours une course spéciale donc je
suis content d'être ici pas donc la
jolie a vu gagner anthony roux de
l'équipe groupama fdj les coureurs sont
maintenant tournés vers le tour de
france départ le 7 juillet de vendée
si vous avez manqué la venue à des
meilleurs cyclistes français / ca
championnat de france à mantes-la-jolie
certains coureurs reviendront le 29
juillet prochain dans les yvelines pour
participer à la dernière étape du tour
de france le peloton s'élancera à 16h15
depuis la ville d'où lieu pour une
dernière étape de 116 km vers les champs
elysées ils passeront notamment par
saint germes en les poissy ou encore
chavenay et rennes moulin nous allons
maintenant ranger les vélos pour parler
de tennis ce n'est chez les sportifs
handisports l'élan courtois johan
guillou du tennis-club de
voisins-le-bretonneux a été a
sélectionné pour participer aux
championnats de france 1re série de
parades tennis en individuel
l'épreuve qui s'est déroulée à ce
week-end à dijon nous avons la chance de
recevoir sur son plateau
le tennisman yvelinois de 32 oeil une 32
ans et johan guillou pour qu'ils nous
débrief son expérience bonsoir
alors comment ça s'est passé et yoann
écouter ça s'est très bien passé pour
moi puisque j'ai fait une performance
j'ai terminé ses championnats 4e j'ai pu
jouer avec les tout meilleurs joueurs de
parra tennis français notamment seraient
cattaneo qui est numéro 3 donc
au classement français c'était une
grande première ces championnats de
france puis s'étaient organisés pour la
première fois par la fft et non plus par
la fédération handisport ce que le para
tennis a été intégré à la fft et ça a
été une grande réussite et on a pu jouer
serein fabuleux fabuleux terrain de la
ligue de franche-comté bourgogne et vous
avez terminé quatrième et j'ai terminé
quatrième
actuellement je suis numéro huit
français donc pour moi c'est des
résultats très encourageants pour la
suite de mon projet tennistique vous
auriez pu mieux faire à votre avis bien
évidemment on peut toujours mieux faire
ouais j'ai eu un peu de pression sur ces
matches peut-être pas assez de
concentration sur les points importants
beaucoup de jeux avec j'irai des jeux
accrochés et je perds quand même là la
petite finale pour la troisième place
voilà je perds en deux sets serrés mais
voilà sur le classement sur le papier le
joueur j'ai affronté été meilleur que
moi j'ai y'a plus qu'à voilà je la
revanche
une prochaine pour une revanche quoi ça
résultat encourageant pour la suite de
la saison
ouais tout à fait parce que j'ai fait
une pause mois entre mi 2016 mi-2017
j'en avais besoin
ça va faire maintenant bientôt huit ans
que je joue je m'étais donné comme
premier objectif une qualification au
championnat de france et je me suis
maintenu en première série donc la
première série c'est quand même les dix
meilleurs joueurs français et donc ces
résultats sont plutôt encourageants
puisque moi ça me permet aussi donc de
progresser au classement français et
également de me conforter conforter ma
place sur le plan international pour les
échéances à venir qui sont comme tout
sportif handisport ça va être la coupe
du monde et jeux paralympiques de tokyo
puis de paris en 2024
donc vous êtes numéro 8 français dans le
top 50 mondial
est ce que finalement c'est votre
classement un classement logique oui oui
tout à fait actuellement c'est un
classement logique puisque comme
beaucoup de sportifs en situation
d'handicap
moi je suis salarié à côté donc j'ai
quand même un travail quasiment à temps
complet vous raconte complet aujourd'hui
donc je m'entraîne selon les
disponibilités que j'ai le soir le
week-end
bien évidemment si j'aurai un
aménagement de temps
avec des temps d'entraînement journée
plus de jours pour faire des
compétitions
je sais que je peux largement améliorer
ce classement mais pour l'instant
aujourd'hui je fais avec ce que j'ai et
on verra bien les opportunités qui
seront offertes
ainsi on va durer venir ça va venir
alors le comité des divines souhaite
également vous donner vous donner le
titre d'ambassadeur pour le département
du para tennis quelle est votre réaction
c'est une immense joie c'est une grosse
responsabilité
c'est une très bonne nouvelle puisque
enfin le département des yvelines va
s'ouvrir pour le développement du bas
rhin tennis donc ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire qu'ils veulent mettre les
moyens dans les clubs livi noah et à
travers donc mon expérience et mon
niveau de jeu de tennis
effectivement le terme en ambassadeurs
me semble vraiment ce qu'il ya de mieux
puisque je vais pouvoir les aider
on va pouvoir communiquer ensemble je
vais pouvoir faire des démonstrations
dans les clubs valides puisque
maintenant comme je les dis le para
tennis est intégré directement la fft et
c'est surtout je pourrai intervenir dans
les centres de rééducation dans les
écoles pour sensibiliser les jeunes au
handicap trouver des jeunes espoirs des
juniors pour leur donner
en tout cas les armes pour qu'ils
puissent peut-être un jour s'ils veulent
faire du haut niveau donc effectivement
tout ça ça va être un partenariat futur
que je suis en train de mener avec le
comité des yvelines donc
comité de tennis de la ligne des
yvelines avec notamment le nouveau
président francis avait hier les géo de
paris c'est votre plus grand rêve oui
dans votre sport oui oui bah les yeux le
fait que le effectivement que les jeux
soient paris je pense que c'est quelque
chose d'important
voilà paris sa a coté c'est notre
capitale on va jouer je jouerai chez moi
si je suis qualifié et puis c'est une
réelle opportunité pour aussi énormément
de d'entreprises qui vont sans doute
soutenir beaucoup de sportifs
paralympiques
voilà moi c'est aussi le cas de celle
qui a cessé ses c'est aussi mon cas
puisque je suis aidé donc par mois une
entreprise donc et le groupe gsf aussi
qui me paraît une depuis quelques années
qui est leader dans les toits les
industriels est également j'espère
pouvoir continuer avec la ligue
donc du coup de tennis ile-de-france et
d'attica le proxy forme d'elancourt qui
ne soutient pas de ma préparation
physique
merci à vous mais passé sur ce plateau
johan guillou on continuera à suivre
avec attention vos futures performances
dans ce à 7,8 sport merci beaucoup merci
des professionnels de la santé du sport
mais aussi des athlètes de haut niveau à
présent ce samedi 30 juin l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
organisé son premier as symposium sur la
prévention sport et santé
c'était à montigny le bretonneux un
rendez vous qui se veut récurrent chaque
année d'ici les jeux olympiques 2024
première édition avec pour thème
prévenir les blessures notamment dans la
pratique du judo et du rugby
propos recueillis par nicolas landry la
médecine est en train d'entrer dans une
nouvelle ère keller de la prévention
l'action doit être mis sur la prévention
prévention à la fois des maladies et par
le sport en particulier et prévention
des récidives de maladie chez les
patients qui ont été malades
là encore grâce au sport judo s'est plus
particulièrement les genoux parce qu'on
est on est vraiment toujours en
équilibre on est sollicité par des
déplacements et puis une opposition
donc c'est vrai que souvent les
ligaments croisés sont touchés par par
une pratique de très haut niveau
également des petits traumatismes au
niveau des mains des doigts des coudes
sur des répétitions mouvement mais on
peut aussi prévenir sa part à la forme
de jeux comme a proposé c'est à dire que
au lieu chez les jeunes de partir sur
des situations où on va demander aux
joueurs d'aller sur une heure
d'entraînement pendant des minutes
d'aller percuter des boucliers ce qui ce
qui est pas très motivant pour les
jeunes on va plutôt essayer de partir
sur sur du jeu d'évitement du jeu de
passes dans lequel ils vont prendre
beaucoup de plaisir
voilà et ça ça permettra d'avoir
peut-être un rugby un peu plus un peu
plus intelligent ou referme ce journal
par des images insolites pour fêter
l'arrivée de l'été la commune de
villepreux organisé pour la toute
première fois une colonne sur le modèle
de la course parisienne
au programme un parcours de 3 km au parc
du trianon avec des obstacles créés avec
des pneus des barrières ou de la paille
à chaque passage la centaine de
participants s'est faite avec de la
poudre biodégradables de couleur bleu
rose ou jaune
on écoute les réactions au micro de
notre journaliste nicolas d'anglais très
sympa
d'accord très cool très colorés ces
sportifs c'est trop bien génial j'en ai
vu de toutes les couleurs
ils nous ont pas rater ça c'est sûr les
obstacles étaient bien sportif olé les
bottes de paille surtout a grimpé à
redescendre avec le temps qui fait
n'était pas évident c'était rigolo et
surtout enfin c'était pas une courbe
tout simple c'était
1depuis
ok c'est la fin de cette émission très
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]